all right let's try let's try e4e four
but this time much slower time controls
okay so we might be entering Marie Lopez
Spanish game Spanish opening back up and
in response to this I'm just going to
support my Center this is something that
Carlson is a fan of this d3 move to
avoid that a Berlin defense now just
Castle or what let me do c3 in case of
b5 it can come all the way back to c2
and I'm gonna try to get in night f1 and
then to g3 before I Castle and see if
it's a good idea or not okay Knight g3
and well let me put a question to that
Bishop oh I could actually pick that up
now I'm winning material
yeah winning material here or mi
calculation time I take the bishop and
hmm take the bishop take the pawn pawn
takes Queen takes Knight Queen takes
pawn is that worthwhile I wonder about
that
I'm not sure what to do here is white
I'm not sure what my candidate moves our
knight takes Bishop I really want to
follow up with Knight takes on E
but I don't know that I'm really getting
anything out of it should I still just
make sure I get that light square bishop
I think so
let me do that and then
I mean just castle I might want to still
have that okay it's not there support my
pond I'm looking for d4 now if b5 do I
play to be three or c2 I think I might
want to play to see to maybe this wasn't
the idea maybe the better idea was to
play f4 night and like night there and
then f4 I should have done that yeah
this is the way to go I should be
focusing on f7 the queen is in a pin now
so I'm assuming b5 is gonna have to be
played let's open it up has to be a bit
uncomfortable for black right now hmm
I'm gonna play here the knight can't
move because of the tension between
these pawns there's a one less defender
now okay however after that I guess
Knight a5 coming up let me back up I
want to maintain my light square bishop
do you have this pawn push I also have
beat three
hmm I also have d5 yeah I'm gonna go
with that and then look to get to c6 I
think I think that could be a really
good spot in fact I might want to push
the night away and then play Knight d4
to c6 or maybe play this first this
Knight is a bit out of play let's keep
him out of play
actually I don't if I play d4 Knight
sits on c4 for a long while Bishop b2
hmm now Bishop b2 bishop D 494 2f 594 to
c6 rook to c1
if the night goes to b7 I played before
and it's boxed out of the game
oh let's see what are the candidate
moves for black I have less than two
minutes here three minutes for black
right now this is a good square and okay
trying to get that majority going and I
think I take and try and target this
pond pressure on that guy
let's get my bishop on this main
diagonal pointing at the king so is this
bishop and okay now let me do this so I
have a convenient reply night before
Bishop beat one and now what I think
this is a good idea I want to get my
Knight to g5 and do some weakness and I
think I avoid the exchange of knights or
do I no no yeah I do but
I was that's not right let's do this I
was thinking that my bishop was actually
right here in that when I play my g5 I
was converging on f7 seeing things seen
a ghost okay so I'm on the oh I just
dropped this pawn I'm getting mated crap
am I really getting mated everything's
fallen everything's falling can I come
back from this is it possible I'm down a
piece a minute six I really have to do
something oh please let me get my pieces
back please please please please please
please oh this is bad news it's bad news
is there safe here oh if I win this it's
gonna be a rabbit out of a hat I tell
you looking for those rabbits defend
against f2 or something uh let me do
that
50 seconds let's go I need to hang on to
my rook I don't know if that's gonna be
possible
f2 out of nowhere I moved way too fast
come on let's go ponies I got to chew up
some time I got to look for the time
chewers oh my king is free to roam
counter-attack come on King hit that no
no no that would have been bad news bad
news hit the night chase him away pin
this is no good this is no good this is
bad I have nothing absolutely nothing my
rook is dead are they gonna move the
knight Ivan there's no way you could
come back from this oh man I'm crying I
want to cry right now wait can I get
this pawn it's not happening it's not
happening is there a draw can I save a
draw
Oh be very scared what am I getting this
oh I just dropped another piece I'm
moving too quick I can't cross I can't
cross I went across oh man that was
terrible f2 you idiot man I was dropping
pieces towards the end I was in pre-move
mode I was getting excited about
grabbing upon I had some hope maybe a
draw maybe maybe
but not after my bishops dead let's go
back back to the drawing board
okay Spanish opening what do we do here
where is there an improvement so far I
have nothing to add here
although wait I don't know what I wonder
about the rook move and the bishop move
I'm not sure about it now it may seem
like what am i doing I'm giving advice
to black now because and I'm the side
that lost but I think there's something
maybe still off with this though I it's
just like the ensuing continuations I
could have I could have been doing
better but I don't know about allowing
me to get that light square Bishop
Bishop g4 h3 goes back I take recaptures
and I mean the position could open up
but I am NOT doing anything with this
clown look at him he's stupid what did
he do the whole game he sat on c2 and he
was big dummy
so I maybe need to get him working worm
so I wonder actually yeah I wonder about
actually this b4 move so this is this
has some of my attention right now
because this I believe is exactly where
he would want to be so I'm I'm hitting
the rewind button I'm seeing you know
how the position of course crumbled for
me and I'm looking for these suggestions
I think a better plan for me is not to
play this silly rook move but rather try
and coordinate my pieces against f7
which is a soft point right now so if I
play Bishop b3 Knight a5 chases it off
the diagonal so that's why I'm thinking
about b4 and then tuck my Bishop to b3
by having b4 I'm controlling a5 there is
no Knight a5 so maybe this is something
to look into
b4 and if there's a strike at my center
maybe I could just be playing Queen e2 I
want to avoid the Queen exchange and
somehow get in this ff4 move I could
maybe be playing Knight h2 and then f4
something so I think that's maybe a way
that I could be improving a different
plan to be taking although I think this
is still good for me
Knight rerouting that was an interesting
idea I think that was nice getting to
that e5 square my opponent was making
good moves and they were strong moves
very good so yeah and I probably
shouldn't have given that pawn up
actually this is this is this was a
blind spot Wow I mean I was I was
thinking of doing this so I could get to
g5 and get to have 7 I was weird it's
thinking my vision was on v3 it's not on
b3 so those are some of the mental
mistakes I was making along the way
right here h4 I could do without that
and I'm just a dead man right here I'm a
dead duck
yep and in fact I think and even cleaner
way to win this position is to well
actually how my opponent played it was
still quite strong maybe just even take
my bishop here and then you're out you
have a rook on this you know it's very
difficult I have a flight squared issues
so maybe that's a slight improvement in
a position where you just already
completely won but yeah totally I saw it
as soon as I moved as soon as I moved
Knight f5 I forgot f2 Oh ugly ugly ugly
ugly ok let me close out let us do
another one I definitely learned
something actually from that game right
there so that that plan right there when
I have that light square bishop - maybe
converge on f7 mental note I am a better
chess player because of that game ok so
thank you for that